so please allow me to extend a warm
welcome to the Neal wheeler Watson
speaker for 2010 bruno latour professor
and vice president for research at lan
stitute the tooth politic the body who
will speak on the topic may nature be
recomposed a few questions of
cosmopolitan thank you
Thank You Raven very much sounds very
much like the sort of argument that
people give before giving the Nobel
Prize it's my only chance to be involved
in this place because this is a place
for the literature Nobel Prize the one
which I'm sure not to get I'm also very
interested to see in the exhibition
beneath but Alfred Nobel had some
trouble with a French he said that the
French are arrogant and that they
believe a brain is a French organ this
is a quote from Alfred Nobel in the
Finland I don't share his arrogance what
I'm going to talk today is trying to
find a word as an alternative to
modernization and the word I want to use
is word composition the nuance I want to
outline is between progress and
progressive it's as if we had to move
from an idea of inevitable progress to
one of progressive tentative and
precautionary progression it's still a
movement it's still a movement forward
but the tenor seems to me entirely
different and since it impossible to
draft something about composition is
amiss out using an ism like communism
futurism surrealism I want to name my
argument composition ISM even though the
word composition ISM is a bit too long
and windy what is nice is that it
underlines the thing I have to put
together while retaining the
heterogeneity and at origin it is really
my main argument tonight also it's
connected with composure it has a clear
route in art painting music theater
dance and thus is associated with
choreography and sonography it's not too
far from compromise and compromising so
there is a certain diplomatic and
prudential flavor to it
above all a composition can fail and
verse retain what is most important
in the notion of constructivism a label
which has already been taken of course
it verse draws attention away from the
irrelevant differences between what is
constructed and what is not constructed
and shifted to varium crucial difference
between what is well-constructed and
what is badly constructed or compose
what is to be composed may at any point
be decomposed composition ISM this takes
up the task of searching for
universality but without believing that
this universality is already there
waiting to be simply unveiled and
discovered it verses far from relativism
in the banal sense of the world as it is
from universalism from universalism it
takes up the task of building up the
common world but from relativism the
certainty that this common world has to
be built from utterly heterogeneous part
but will never make a whole but at best
a fragile revisable and diverse
composition now I have to say that I'd
prepare slides but I didn't realize most
of you people will not see my slide in
the small screen obviously this is
another price of literature not for a
liberal and very rarely people in
literature use slides apparently so I
decided to switch off on Charlie the
slide that no one will see and maybe in
the discussion I'll show some of it so I
will stick to words like we do in
literature even for the word first
natural begins to pop up for instance in
early space lateral environmentalism
composition ISM would probably be more
comfortable with the word three
naturalism or even more shocking multi
naturalism critique which is the
opposition of composition in this
argument was wedded to a very odd
definition of nature taken here as the
discovery revelation unveiling of what
lay behind the subjective fog of
appearances
and what insured this is the key
argument I want to discuss with you the
continuity in space and time of all
beings in their inner reality it has
long been realized by science studies my
own field some eminent people of as
feeders here actually and in a much
wider way by all sort of environmental
movement that the character of the age
is precisely not the taking into account
of at last nature but the complete
dissolution of nature in brief ecology
or rather political ecology is the end
of nature nature is not a finger a
domain a real an ontological territory
it is a rather it has been during the
modern countess's a way of organizing
the division what Whitehead calls the
bifurcation of nature between
appearances and reality subjectivity and
objectivity history and immutability a
fully transcendent a fully historical
construct a deeply religious way but not
in the religious sense of the world to
create the difference of potential
between what human souls were attached
to and what was really out there and
also as I have shown elsewhere a fully
political way of distributing power in
what I have called the modernist
Constitution a sort of unwritten compact
between what could be and what could not
be discussed not an ideal way as one can
easily see now to establish a political
ecology if you begin to trace beforehand
what can be discussed and what is
absolutely out of any discussion this
was the time of a great political
religious legal and epistemological
invention of matters of fact and
bettered in ojas extensa devoid of any
meaning except that of being the
ultimate reality made non vélez of
it is fully silent and yet able for the
mysterious intervention of science
capital s of speaking by themselves but
without the mediation of science small s
and scientist this whole modernist
sonography primary quality and secondary
quality to use the philosophical term
appear to us now the queerest
anthropological construction especially
because progress under the labor of
reason capital here was defined as the
quick substitution of his odd nature to
what remains subjective local cultural
human valued the more natural we would
become the more rational we will be and
the easier will be the agreement between
all reasonable human beings this
composition now lies in ruin but without
having been superseded by any other more
realistic and especially more livable
this construction in that sense we are
still postmodern this is precisely the
point where composition ISM wishes to
take over what is the successor of the
notion of nature of course no one has
ever lived in nature in various extents
our sense of the world no Adam no virus
no organism no technical project has
ever resided in has extensa they have
all lived in the pre rivers to use James
term where else could have lived where
else could have they found their abode
as soon as the bifurcation had been
invented at the time of Descartes and
Locke it has been immediately undone by
philosophers poets and of course
scientists no composition was so
fiercely decomposed remember we have
never been modern so this utopia of
nature has always been just that a
utopia a word of Beyond without any
realistic grasp on for practice
of science technology commerce and
industry this is what is so surprising
and yet it has retained the same
enormous power over the political
epistemology of a mother not a power of
explanation of course but the power to
create this very difference of potential
but has given critique its steam and
modernism its impetus so the question
now for those who wish to inherit from
modernism without being postmodern is
what it is to live without this
difference of potential when will we get
the energy to act without such a
gigantic steam engine so to speak where
will composition ISM takes its steam
what will be to move forward without
this engine of nature and to move
collectively at is billions of people
and their trillions of affiliates and
commensal such a total disconnect
between the ruins of naturalism on the
one hand and the slow and painful
emergence of its successor could be made
very clear in the sunny bout of
agitation during the Copenhagen event or
non-event I should say in Copenhagen
around what has been called the
Climategate I'm sure many of you have
followed it carefully
suddenly critiques and proponents of the
entropic cause of climate change
realized by sifting for thousands of
email and put climate scientists but had
been robbed by activists of very dubious
pedigrees we know that now but
scientific fact of a matter had to be
slowly composed and by whom by humans by
squabbling humans assembling data having
instrument to make the climate speak
instrument can you believe that and
spotty data set that imagine that and
both scientists had money problems
grants quench and we are to message
right correct and rewrite humble texts
nautical what text
written the science made of text how
shocking what was so interesting in the
hysterical reaction of scientists and
the press was of almost full agreements
of opponents and proponents who seem to
share the same idea love science capital
as if science is slow decompose it
cannot be true said the skeptic if we
reveal how it's composed said the
proponents of entropy cause it will be
discussed that's disputable thus it
cannot be true again the old opposition
between what is constructed and what is
not constructed instead of a slight but
crucial Devils between what is well and
what is badly constructed on composed
and this revelation just at the moment
when the dispute ability of the most
important tenets of what it is for
billions of humans represented by the
heads of state to live collectively on
the planet was fully visible in the vast
pandemonium of the biggest diplomatic
fare ever assembled
clearly when faced with a stunning
revelation of a climate gate it will not
be enough to rejoice in the discovery of
a humble human dimension of scientific
practice with which this would still be
believing in the banking bit still be
equipped with the armament of critique
as if again we had to oppose the pure
realm of unmediated and undisputable
fact to that of squabbling humans we
want amends and truth together says the
composition
or to use my language we want matters of
concern not simply matters of fact it
was the ideal moment to connect the
dispute ability of politics and the
dispute ability of science small-ass
instead of trying to maintain against
all evidence the usual gap
- in what is politics and what can be
discussed and science capital s that is
beyond dispute so a composition is
nothing is beyond dispute and yet
closure has to be achieved but by the
slow process of composition and
compromise not by the revelation of the
world of beyond just before Copenhagen
the French philosopher Michel Sir wrote
in the newspaper Libya has shown a
rather nice piece summarizing the
argument he had made some of you
probably know this book the natural
contract the paper was called la Nonna
VT also made the Copa nag that is the
one not invited and the summit this was
of course Gaia whom I call something
else for some strange reason Sarah
peace point to an empty seat in
Copenhagen Parliament of thing that of
the earth and he wanted how to make it
sit and speak and be represented
unfortunately sir solution was to join
together the language rituals and
practice of politics good at
representing humans and the language
procedures and rituals of science good
at reproducing fact but this is easier
said but Don what he dreamed much like
hands John us earlier in the 20th
century was in effect government of
scientist a modern a modernist dream if
any able to speak the two languages at
once a very French temptation from the
government a savant
during the revolution all the way to our
atomic program and our celebration of
course technique Delita
I've been teaching for 25 years in one
of them but if those two languages are
inheritors of a great bifurcation we
have not moved an inch we would have
simply conjoined the worst of politics
with the worst of science but is the
truth traditional way to put
undisputed bility we have been there
already
this was the dream of Marxism just as it
is today dream now in tatters of run of
a mill economist a science of politics
instead of a total transformation or
what it is to do politics how to
represent nonhumans and what it is to do
science with entangle and controversial
scientists all the way down around
disputable matters of concern to believe
in this government I serve on has been
precisely the mistake made by so many
environmentalist when they interpreted
the present crisis as the great comeback
of nature instead of its total demise
between the belief in nature and the
belief in politics one has to choose
needless to say that the Copenhagen
event wasn't that respect completely and
probably predictably failure not that we
have as yet no word government able to
enforce the decision in the unlikely
case there would have been any but
because we have has had no idea of what
it is to govern the world now that
nature as an organizing concept or
conceit rather is gone
we can't leave on planet earth not on
Pandora I've been very taken by
Cameron's thinman avatar but I will save
you this part because it's a beautiful
film in my view on how we simulate the
fact that we cannot live on Pandora
meaning we can't live in view either so
we can't live here
one thing is sure and the Climategate is
a good case in point it's actually
impossible to reuse the division between
science and politics invented by the
modern even by conjoining them true
artificial construction put together
make four third artificial contrivance
not for a solution to problem
very consciously impossible at the birth
of a 17th century as shipping and
scheffers have shown many years ago
somewhere between a Hobson's boil to
point or out at locus classic use of
science studies nature was invented to
render politics impotent there is no
reason why a politics of nature ever
deliver a better promise I now have a
feeling more and more every day that we
are actually closer to the 16th century
than to the 20th century very much for
the same reason as Stephen Toulmin
argues in his book cosmopolitan
precisely because the settlement but as
created with bifurcation in the first
place lies in ruin and ask to be
entirely we come host which means that
we find a strand of familiarity with the
time before it's invention and
implementation when people derived the
time before the epistemology called
break to use all to say a favorite food
modernist expression it's because
earlier a peace term a visitor also in
Foucault of course was making too many
connection between what we called the
micro and the macro cosmos but is it not
exactly what we now see emerging
everywhere under the name of post
natural the destiny of all the cosmos or
rather Cosmo is now fully interconnected
now that for our very progress and for
our own very proliferating numbers we
have taken the earth on our shoulder as
is made so clear by the striking
neologism and troppo seen of course what
is entirely lost today is the notion of
a nominee between the two micro and
macro but what varies and there should
be a connection between those two
destiny this seems now obvious to all
and there might be many more than to the
human and the nonhuman as any reader of
a 16th century boiling
Agron may easily gather four centuries
later micro and macro cosmos are now
literally literally and not only
metaphorically connected and the result
is so to speak is to speak Greek a
cosmos horrible and disgusting mess yes
but a cosmos is a cosmos nonetheless
hence the word Cosmopolitan's which is
not used as a way to say cosmic bullet
meaning universal but as a politics of a
cosmos at any rate it's certainly no
longer resemble the bifurcated nature of
a recent past with on the one hand
primary qualities real speechless
speaking by themselves that alas devoid
of any meaning and any value going one
way while the secondary quality
subjective meaningful choco-chip full of
value but alas empty of any reality go
their own separate way in that sense we
feel at least I feel closer than ever
from the time of before the famous
epistemological break a radical divide
that has always been radically thought
but never of course actually practiced
since we have never been money when Alex
and Kohei wrote from the closed world to
the infinite universe little could he
predict that barely half a century later
the infinite universe had become a final
finite or involved or implicated cosmos
again there is no way to devise the
successor to nature if we do not tackle
again
the tricky question of animism one of
the principal cause of irony poured by
the modern upon the 16th century as you
know is that was poor
cake Falls what the misfortune of living
on the wrong side of a epistemological
break believed in a world animated by
all sort of entities and forces instead
of believing like any rational mind into
an inanimate matter producing its effect
only for power of its antecedent closes
it this conceit that is at the root of
all the critique of environmentalist as
being anthropocentric because they
attribute values Christ's agency purpose
to what cannot have and should not have
any intrinsic value Lions whales viruses
co2 monkeys ecosystem or worth of all
Gaia the accusation of entrepreneurism
is so strong but it paralyzed all their
thought of many scientists in many field
but especially barratry to go beyond the
narrow constraint of what is called
materialism or reductionism it
immediately gives to the a thought a
sort of New Age flavor as if the default
position was the idea of the inanimate
and the bizarre innovation was that of a
animate ad agency there must be mad or
marginal consider Lovelock for instance
and it's absurd idea of the earth as
requires eye organism but what should
appear extraordinary bizarre in my view
is on the country the invention of
inanimate entity which would do nothing
else but carry one step further the
codes that make them act to the n plus
one consequence for which they are inter
nothing but the clues this conceit as
the strange result to compose the world
with long concatenation of causes and
effect where this is what is odd nothing
is supposed to happen except probably at
the beginning but there is no god a
living
the disappearance of agency in the
so-called materialist worldview is a
stunning invention especially because
it's contradicted every single time by
the odd resistance of reality every
consequence added slightly to the coos
verse it has to have some sort of agency
there is a supplement a gap between the
two if not there would not be even a way
to discriminate the coals from a
consequence this is true in particle
physics as well as in chemistry biology
psychology and of course sociology thus
although in practice every agency has to
be distributed at each step throughout
the whole concatenation in theory
nothing happens but the strict
transportation without deformation of a
clues to use my technical language
although every stage of affair manifest
association of mediators everything is
supposed to happen as if only chains of
purely passive intermediary add to
enfold paradoxically the most stubborn
realism the most rational outlook is
predicated on the most unrealistic the
most contradictory notion of an action
without agency without agency of course
it had one great advantage that of
ensuring the continuity of space and
time by connecting all entity throughout
concatenation of causes and consequence
no composition necessary for this
assembly of nature it's already
assembled nature is always already
assembled since nothing happens but what
is coming from before it is enough to
have a cause the consequence will follow
adding nothing of their own
except the caring fervor of the same
undisputable set of characteristics let
them go and they will build up the cage
of nature
anyone who deny their existence we
introduce discontinuities people like
Darwin people like vana guru everybody
studying project instead of object the
whole science studies and so on most of
biology
who let agency proliferate pointing out
many interesting gaps between closes and
consequence will be considered different
a madman a dreamer not a rational being
anyway if there is one thing about which
to wonder in the history of modernism
it's not that there are still people mad
enough to believe in animism but that so
many hard adult finca have invented what
should be called in animism and I've
tried to be sheer impossibility their
definition of what it is to be rational
and scientific it's in animism that is
the queer invention an agency without
agency constantly denied by practice
this is what lies at the heart of the
modernist Constitution and as the great
French entrepreneur is Philip de scole a
so nicely shown in this book what makes
it even other is that this in animism
that's what he called naturalism is the
most anthropocentric of the whole full
mode of relation invented according to
him across the world to these will to
deal with collectives of humans and
nonhumans all of the other I run you
that therefore in the scheme of this
crap I a nice slide that you won't see
them are trying to underline as much as
possible the agency at each step
especially the one which is a counter
position of naturalism that is called
animism precisely but for purely and PO
centric very political reason naturalist
which is basically
I assume the Swedes I'm the same
entrepreneurship goal category as we
French I mean not as this modernist
that's impossible but basically
naturalist I've built their collective
to make sure that subject and object
culture and nature be utterly distinct
of course not in reality but in the web
we present Association this is why
rationalist never detect the
contradiction between what they say
about the continuity of causes and
consequence and what they have to
witness but is the discontinuity the
invention was suplement the creativity
of course wider term creativity is
ultimate between association of
mediators they have simply transformed
this discrepancy but would have made
their worldview untenable into a radical
divide between human human subject and
non-human object I mean I have to
explain a little bit about in for those
of you d'etre one better way to say it
is that Livy straws mentioned a very
interesting experiment going on at the
time of a valladolid controversy during
the Valladolid controversy the monks and
the priests and the bishop were trying
to see the Indians as you know out of
Seoul but at the meantime mean at the
same time says latest was on the coast
of Panama book the Indians were trying
to see if the Spanish had a body and
that was the big worry because everyone
there as the soul but a body that's
disputable
so they took prisoners from the spit
from Spanish and put them in big vats of
water to let them drown and see if they
watch or not if the rot it means they
have a body indeed if it don't it means
they are just so so of a shame and live
shows with this tongue-in-cheek says on
the whole the Indian we're more
scientists like because they believed in
natural science instead of believing in
social science like the monks and the
bishops now on that anecdote Vivier the
Castro and this could have been the
whole very interesting argument of
anthropology
but we believe we have the same buddies
and / our souls and opinions and
subjectivity while the Indians imagine a
large part of the rest of the world
east of C Bay and so on this is exactly
the opposite is that we all animals
plants and of course human by default
our human society but we are divided by
our bodies so the big point for us is
solipsism how do we know we share
opinions and the big time for Indians is
actually the danger of an anthro
profession that you cannibalism you you
might eat a human instead of eating
anyone anyway this is just to remind you
that Indians don't live in nature they
never had nature to live in nature's was
completely entre political historical
connection a very very small short time
and highly specific completely
anthropocentric according to this color
definition of what it is to establish
connection between human and non-human
rationalist have simply transformed this
discrepancy into a radical divide
between you and human subject and
non-human afflict extraordinary feat
having made for a purely anthropocentric
reason the accusation of being
anthropocentric a deadly weapon in the
fight for establishing the continuity of
space and time without having to compose
it it has been the most anthropomorphic
who have succeeded in rejecting all the
other as practicing the most horrible a
kike dangerous and reactionary form of
animism
I wish not to have this argument
confused with the plea against
reductionism in all discipline
reductionism offers enormous ly useful
handles to allow scientists to insert
the instrument time their paradigm and
to produce long series of practical
effect but with success at handling
entities by generating result and
Industry out of them is
not the same thing as building the cage
of nature with its long chains of causes
and consequence it's actually exactly
the opposite the what reductionism shows
in practice is that only the
proliferation of Engineers the tool of
highly localized set of skill is able to
extract interesting and useful result
from a multitude of agencies and if the
question time gets too tough I would ask
my two colleagues here of science to be
much better and much more qualified than
me to show you some example of it in
physics especially consider how
fabulously useful the central dogma of a
first version of DNA has been to begin
to unlock the power of gene and yet
there is no active biologist to believe
that this earlier version could be of
any use to build the naturalistic
definition of what it is for an organism
to live there is a complete and
continuously growing disconnect between
the efficient handles and the
scenography of nature once you
background this proliferation of tricks
and knacks and skills you do not define
the nature of thing you simply enter
into something else on Charlie the
spurious continuity of nature and the
same could be shown every time you move
from the reductionist handles to
reductionism as a philosophical that is
a political worldview composition is
however cannot rely on such a ploy the
continuity of all the agents in space
and time is not given to them as it was
to naturalist but big Devils they have
to compose it slowly and progressively
and to compose it from discontinuous
pieces not only because human destiny
microcosm and non-human destiny
macrocosm are now entangled for everyone
to see contrary to a strand dream of
bifurcation between primary and
secondary qualities but for a much
deeper reason
on which depends the very capture of a
creativity of all agencies consequences
other flow over hoses and this overflow
has to be respected everywhere in every
domain every discipline and for every
type of entity it's no longer possible
to build the cage of nature and indeed
it has never been possible to live in
this cage we are not in zoo this is
after all what is meant by the a cause
of ecology call it animism if you wish
but it will no longer be enough to brand
it with the mark of infamy
this is indeed why we feel so close to
the 16th century as if we were back
before the epistemological break before
the odd invention of matter as wydad
throw a highly idealist construct as is
shown in concept of nature a very
important book for that argument of
course as science studies has documented
other another again the notion of matter
is too political too anthropomorphic too
narrowly hysterical to ethnocentric to
be about able to define the stuff out of
which were poor human race expels from
modernism as to build its abode we need
to have a much more material much more
mundane much more eminent but above all
much more realistic definition of a
material world if we wish to compose
this common world also for a reason that
would have seen not as important in the
sixteenth century but which is the
hallmark of us as I alluded to with the
Climategate namely the proliferation of
scientific controversy this is a
well-known phenomenon but it impossible
to emphasize at this juncture what makes
really impossible now to rely animal on
the continuity of space and time implied
in the notion of nature and its
undisputable chains of causes
consequence is worth for grounding of a
very practice of science and of the many
controversy inside the science
themselves once again this phenomenon is
lamented by rationalist who still wish
to paint science is able to produce
incontrovertible undisputable mouth
shutting matters of fact but if I dare
say the fact of the matter is that
matters of fact are in great risk of
disappearing like so many other
endangered species or else they are
dealing with drifting subject of no
interest to anyone anymore if you think
of it where are now the topics where you
do not see publicly scientists disagree
among themselves on what it is how it
should be studied finance portrait
defuse understood or cast facts have
become issues and the more important of
issue the least certain we are now
publicly are of how to handle them think
of Africa around the h1n1 influenza of a
volcano hash which is never very nice
Kate red tuna and one of my favorite is
actually red tuna because Sarkozy is
associated with red tuna in a very nice
way and ladies and gentlemen this is
good this is good at least for
compositional
since it now adds a third source of
discontinuity forcing all of us
scientists activists politicians alike
to compose the common word from
disjointed pieces instead of taking for
granted that the unity continuity
agreement is already there and better
into the same nature fits all the
increase of dispute ability and the
amazing extension of scientific
technical controversy while somewhat
terrifying at first is also the best
have to finally take seriously the
political task of establishing the
continuity of all entities that make up
the Commonwealth again between nature
and politics one has to choose
I hope it's now clear why I said earlier
that why this choice was so important if
you have a nature of a composition and
the continuity is already made we are
united - and divided only by secondary
qualities once nature is not there we
have to compose the common word from
disjointed paths to conclude I have his
trans fantasy that the modernist hero
had never actually looked to the future
but always to the past the archaic past
that he was flying in terror I don't
wish to embrace Benjamin's angel of
history tired trope but there is
something right in the position he
attributed to the angel it looks behind
and not ahead but contrary to benjamine
interpretation the modern who is flying
backward yeah this is very odd if I was
a dancer I would do it very well but I'm
not so flying backward it's very
actually very difficult I have a dancer
was doing for me but modern was flying
backward is not is actually not seeing
the destruction he's generating in his
flight since they happen in his back
it's only recently by a sudden
conversion a metanoia of sort but here e
aya put it a he it has to be your he for
some reason he has suddenly realized how
much catastrophe his development as
tweeted behind him the ecological crisis
is nothing but the sudden turning over
of someone who had actually never before
looked into the future so busy it was to
extricate himself from a horrible past
okay there is something a diplom in this
hero fleeing this path so fiercely but
he cannot realize except to late but
it's precisely his flight but as created
the destruction he was trying to avoid
in the first place tragic it was with
Oedipus pursued by decay the faith rain
as you know even above God but with a
modern there is no God so it's actually
no tragedy no simply gigantic myopic
bloody and sometimes comical blunder
actually just like with charge of the
people in the sky from I whine avatar
for those of you everyone modems have
never contemplated their future until a
few years back that's my argument they
were too busy fleeing the past in terror
and the great advance we'd be made in
the Anthropology if we were able to
discover
what ha they were freeing but give them
so much energy to flee when the modern
called what the modern called their
future was never seen face to face since
this was the future of someone fleeing
once past backward wait I agree this is
why their future what they call their
future before the turnaround is always a
utopia happed
completely hyped the French language for
one switch of an English may
differentiate the future de l'avenir
in French I could say that the moderns
add a future but never until a few years
back and a veneer to define the present
situation I have to translate and said
that the modern always had a future
this odd utopian future of someone
fleeing his past in Reverse ok but never
chance until recently that is to turn
what I call their prospect trying to
find a word for a venir the shape of
things to come at them as it's now clear
from the ecological crisis the future
and the prospect there has almost no
resemblance to one another no more than
matters of fact and matters of concern
or critique and Composition what makes
the time we are in so interesting is
that we are progressively discovering
but just at the time when people are
desperate to see the might in the end of
no future we suddenly have many prospect
but so utterly different from what we
imagined while fleeing backward ahead
fleeing backward but we are casting them
only as so many fragile illusion or
depending on which ecological school
but in catastrophe the first reaction is
to do nothing so strong is the modernist
temptation to exclaim let us free as
before and have our past future back
instead of saying let's uh stop freeing
abandon our future journal back finally
to our past
finally and explore our new prospect
what lies ahead
the fate of things to come
of course what we see when we do that is
not pretty
no pressure than what was unfolding in
the spiritual eyes of the Angelus Novus
in Benjamin's fable to be sure it's not
a welcome posed cosmos a beautiful and
our mo news Pandorum planet but as I
said a rather our horrendous cosmos now
think of it how would the modern had
succeeded in assembling anything
properly while never looking at it this
is what is so extraordinary the
entrepreneur G of the mother it would be
like playing the piano while turning
once back to the keyboard how do you
assemble a cosmos it's impossible to
compose without being firmly attending
the task at hand but for horror for ha
it does not have the same feature than
the archaic past we fled in terror for
so long for one good reason from this
hall the one that comings at us
you cannot free it's coming at you this
is the great
what is so bizarre and so powerful in
Lovelock's right
not because he's a great writer but
because gala is coming at us no use to
speak of epistemological brakes anymore
breaking with the task will not do nor
critique will be open yet it's time to
compose in all the meaning of the word
including to compose ways that is to
compromise to care to move slowly with
crucial and precaution that's quite a
new set of skill to learn imagine that
innovating as never before
but with precaution this is why it was
so difficult to train engineers when I
was at the school of mine I mean what it
is to innovate with precocial suddenly
another himself will never succeed to
great temptation again inherited from a
time of a great flight abandon all
innovation but Frankenstein's story in
normal with innovate as before without
any precaution but modernist
paraphernalia have to be remade one by
one for the task but now lying her head
and no longer behind Oedipus has met
with Sphinx and she said look ahead well
the moderns of course knowing now fully
well that they are blind fumbling in the
dark led sorry blind led by blind are in
great need of new captures and senses
well you might have noticed that there
is some connection between composition
ISM and communism especially the
Communist Manifesto a belief in critique
in Wadi colquitt eke a commitment to a
fully idolized material world a total
confidence in the science of economics
economics of all Sciences a delight in
the transformative power of negation at
rushed in dialectics a complete
disregard for precaution and abandon of
Liberty in politics behind critique
liberalism and above all and absolutely
trust in the inevitable rust of progress
so the comparison doesn't look so good
and yet the true argument of something
in common
namely the search for the common the
thirst of a common word is what varies
of communism in composition ISM we see
small but crucial deference but it has
to be slowly composed instead of being
taken for granted and imposed everything
happens as if a human race was on the
move again expels from one utopia that
of economics and in search of another
one that of ecology two different
interpretation of his precious little
root acres the first one being a
dystopia but the second being a promise
but absolutely no one knows as yet how
to fulfill how a livable and breathable
home can be built for those errant
masses that is the only question worth
whizzing in composition ISM and to
finish on Avatar there is hope in
Pandora's Box I should say that Cameron
actually took his idea from his Finn for
my own book called Pandora's Hope why
did he call his planet Pandora's if not
because he bred Pandora's hope there is
hope in Pandora's Box but how deep one
has to go in order to fetch it that's
for us ladies and gentlemen to decide
thank you very much for inviting me
tonight
you